I don't know I don't know what the
puzzles are for ya bogan you know I'm
young you begin you well eh anyway it's
it's Jerry no no Aaron and we're gonna
get this podcast up and running
we've been experimenting with
experiments we've instrumented with
making content yeah more regularly
we ran into some troubles at sound class
and now we're gonna do that out here and
hope things are gonna be on things we're
gonna be on YouTube you listen to a
video
hey no people do that there are podcast
news even at a certain point you know
you can do just about anything anything
sort of like filming the pages of a book
and trying to make people read them like
you can do read this book at 240p I
can't make out the letters because my
internet connection isn't strong enough
we give read me this book in high res
dammit yeah this this Starbucks Internet
is really not giving me the upload
speeds I need or whatever makes that
work we just got done talking for two
hours just listen who's got done for
talking for two hours about Dave's X
minus X dinosaurs just just ex machina
just ex machina Alex garland you want in
a bunch of those I feel like any way we
sit down and talk it's always like there
is a topic but it's kind of like hidden
in a nice like gauzy um our conversation
wonderful our conversations are like
choral works like it looks like it's
just gonna be growing in one direction
but then there's all these branches
everywhere yeah that's all one choral
yeah it's all one wreath you know
someone someone whatever the skeleton
part is called yeah EXO crust
of course maybe the name of my [ __ ]
metal band so cuz my grindcore band now
EXO crust you'll play some new metal ass
[ __ ] now EXO Cressman
I don't feel like grindcore because you
like you can't EXO crust doesn't equal
like passionate wrapping a bit about
like personal struggles yeah EXO Kris
would not have done it all for than
Nikki no I mean nothing for them EXO
trust never has one of those days
yeah you just don't want to wake up
everything sex you just want to justify
so de guess dubs think a smock enough
6.0 coming back we're gonna we're gonna
try and record these more frequently
yeah
go ahead and be less [ __ ] give us
comments so we know what we're doing
because we don't yeah this is very loose
this is a very loose episode it's
alright so I'm sure I will be I will be
sharper next time movie cool good so
enjoy all right welcome back they'll
come and beyond of the new welcome
awesome Vida sin
no it's from cabaret and I never I don't
know the second line first
he'll come and Bienvenue welcome it's
like how many how many audience is go to
cabaret that are both German French and
English speaking you just have an equal
smattering it's why it's so hard to put
on a production right it's like you
gotta find a city with the right
demographic and then if there's one
Portuguese guys the audience you're
[ __ ] okay there's nothing for you're
just turning X to the X to the German
just like what are you singing
there's one night a weekend that have a
Portuguese translator that flies in
nobody does everything a Portuguese sign
language well you guys German sign
language in Portuguese there's two guys
because I just realized this guy has to
be deaf to need like a an interpreter
that won't be distracting to have a
language interpreter for a play who just
sits next to yous like telling where the
gold is now like say just reciting
things out even telling you lie just
reporting it yeah people around you
that's just like all the theatre can
afford to have a guy sit there and tell
you what's happening yeah he's just like
a dude that just kind of like shabbily
dressed yeah I hope he doesn't even give
you Karen is just like so that guy just
points yeah whispers to you in your life
yeah oh man that would be distracting
yeah imagine somebody doing that but
they're not it's not the language you
speak
you're not helping me understand
anything that would almost make it
scarier just cuz that's like really
there's something unnerving objectivity
we're just some dudes and it's sitting
next to you whispering in German yeah
cuz it's like after a while it's gonna
get to you cuz you're still in a
confined space a little bit like you're
in these chairs you don't want to
disrupt a plane that's German guy
whispering into your like even if you
know what he's there for you start to
wonder like maybe he's telling me that
at all like maybe he's subliminally
program if he's maybe he's programming
me to be straight there's a I've been
reading that Chuck Klosterman book and
there's a thanks bro yeah for those of
you playing along at home a hair in my
face so they look like a wig hair I was
well I was it was a need even with
yesterday don't need even yours waiting
in wigs yeah was like you know I seen a
Star Wars were there and the big trash
compactor was like
Thanks or you did you have to like were
you trying to pick out a good wig so
that you looked human when you left yeah
exactly
my Barry Niall mo yeah I just put my
skin suit back on look I need a way to
sell this yeah yeah otherwise everyone's
just gonna see my weird my hey my green
crystal glass brain hey that was really
cool yeah it was really cool that was
very very cool and like of all the ways
because it seems to me like a struggling
point for a lot of AI movies lately is
like how do we want you know introduced
where the consciousness is being held
and how it works like and usually it's
just like a computer or something like a
regular computer and in this movie since
it's so like advanced I like that they
actually came up with a pretty smart
version of that technology of a brain
the brain being this kind of like it's a
specific crystallized material that has
some kind of plasticity built into it
yeah kind of restructure on the fly the
way you know the nerve map of the brain
does in real life yeah exactly people
and so it's like to change or use a
piece of technology like that instead of
just like I mean there's oh my computer
accident look at I wanted a little more
like sophisticated yeah although I do
think it would be crazy if you saw an AI
movie where you know the robotic body of
the AI either it's got a wireless sync
up to the brain which is just like a
giant room full of supercomputer
cabinets that are all that are all
hooked up to the body remotely true so
dudes it does that happen in
transcendence I think sort of like you
saw it I didn't when they upload his
personality or whatever I could have
sworn it's in this giant room like an
open it's like an owl routes through a
computer because now he lives in the
internet but like the the main like AI
they have is like just a giant room
filled with server upon server platform
server well either want to see that or I
want to see like the brain is just kind
of in the torso because that's the only
place that has enough room for all the
big computer components and everything
so the robot just kind of can't move a
whole lot
he's just sort of stiff wasted I feel
like that's sort of a zania
like a zany hiccup in the progress of
getting AI you know to to its fullest
potential is like technology always like
form you get has to be adjusted over
time so like the first a eyes will be
like just kind of a trash can fill these
parts that has a microphone where I can
talk to you yeah like and that over the
years they'll start making them more and
more humanoid than them you know but I'm
sort of like we designed this for
efficiency and being able to cool down
yeah what we it's like what we need is
the the guy who pioneers the first like
real life AI we need him to be kind of a
narcissist who wants to [ __ ] the hey I
like immediately yeah that's why that's
why he even looks the way he does it's
like I mean it's very it's like thanks
rocket does a really great job of like
like very maturely handling the fact
that this is a robot capable of
sexuality yeah it does a fantastic job
of like dealing with that issue except
like skirting by it or like making it
way too hallmark II like in Bicentennial
man I did not see nice and say I saw
there's a kid was it good I I liked it
as a kid because Bicentennial oh man
such a lungs it was a 50 yeah or no way
is that's 200 what's the sense anymore
for Centennial's to Bicentennial is 200
yes Esquith Centennial is 150 sorry I
can never tell what it means to of or
half of yeah so like biannual like which
one is it yeah it was like or which by
month do not what to twice a month or
every every second month yeah because
both of those exists yeah
we need a better we need a third like
three fixed worth yeah it should be like
buy and be because it's like in
traverses inter like you know doing a
little more quick get on that Webster
yeah word Smith's yeah anybody who's not
Oxford on the Oxford English Dictionary
pays me on what or the Oxford English
Dictionary you cuz they're always the
ones adding [ __ ] words like more
like selfie dude dude they were the ones
who language of all's somebody okay fine
but like okay
language does involved but somebody told
me this and if it is true I'm calling
the most massive [ __ ] possible
somebody said they changed they added a
second definition to the word literally
to accommodate the way people use it now
yeah which if that's true that's
[ __ ] you can't do that you can't
make a word mean itself and also not
itself here's the thing people to get a
stick up their ass ones like you're not
saying literally I'm like yeah they're
not saying literally they're not they
don't literally mean literally they're
saying literally ironically yeah I know
but people have lost like I feel like it
at a certain point some people know that
they're doing that and some people don't
Oh some people genuinely some people
think the word literally just is an
enhancer and that's what it means
oh okay they just think literally is
just like a qualifier that makes it is
just for stress yes like I'm sure some
people understand the ironically the
irony where you're like there were
literally like a million people there
because it's like don't really just
exaggerating that hard you're speaking
in hyperbole yeah and then but I'm sure
they're just as many people who are like
I just literally died yeah when people
want to enhance their thing they say
literally and that's what that word
means not you know that it actually did
happen and you're not using that right
so it's like if to amend the word in a
dictionary in a way that encompasses
that this that [ __ ] phrase the word
that the rules don't matter let me ask
you this when literally can't mean
literally and also not literally yeah
like unless it's like written in that
font that means like literally means
happening in actuality D or in reality
and then literally as the second
definition it's like yeah like totally
happily like it's super totally happened
dude and the mouse offs make me one
[ __ ] scream I wanna see even those
without word things it's literally not
best thank you till thank you Father
John til stays Thank You mr. father I
also want to replace the word totes in
society with toast yeah like I know this
toast elite happy no I'm not even that
not even that hard just like toast like
you long ago the movies Toad's yeah
toast yeah no that's stupid no it's a
good idea do it it's like um
for cool stuff I wanted to seep a new
word in society so that cool stuff for
chill stuff was free remember when epic
was like being way over done and we were
trying to get myth off the ground Oh
miss do ya this huh but I'm glad that
epic has like kind of fallen apart like
epic has gone away is kind of chilled
he's cooled down kind of chill you know
I think he's pretty chilly epic is
pretty fridge now so you don't have to
we don't have to adapt myth I still like
although I never adopted the wind fail
epic system and now I'm just waiting for
the day where like you know cuz cuz
people say rad now cuz it's you know a
call back it's like nostalgic so coming
back so in 15 years or so people are
gonna start saying uh epic and win
because we might like referential
ironically who's gonna be like a
throwback yeah can you imagine what to
take me home tonight but about the 2010s
is gonna be like something about shaking
your asses there's so many so much
popular music is dedicated to the rich
so know what is the movie the movie take
you to take me home tonight like the
Topher Grace like 80s throwback yeah not
the song take me home tonight but you
would have to name it after attractive
fling in a condo yes which is already
like featuring a retro sample yeah
exactly it's like whatever the track is
called is gonna be something silly yeah
it's like take me home that works isn't
it'll work this is a challenge that I
movie whereas I feel like there would be
just champagne on everyone in the in the
updated version yeah champagne and
cellphones yeah the take me home tonight
movie but about the 2010s is going to
look like the banner for an elite daily
article yeah god [ __ ] that website oh
man well okay let's see it I don't you
know it it would have to be the name of
either like a booty jam or like one of
those uplifting March songs because like
those are the two songs yeah like um oh
god like wake me up by Avicii
yeah yeah or like um even that stuff
like you know like imagine dragons does
that now like you know haha but mala
yeah it's all like God what is going on
like are we going to are we trying to
get ready for a new war what is this
like well yes very party March song no
yeah that's been the thing it's like
there's that American authors song they
all have that this sort of like slightly
Americana like there's always some kind
of like a mandolin or a ukulele
instrument thrown in and it always has
at least it harkens sonically to that
you know like those Levi's commercials
that are all like warm golden sunlight
through tall grass and like Americana
[ __ ] like it all feels like it came out
of a place that looked like that yeah
there's so many of those songs now so I
feel like it would be one of those or it
would be a booty yeah cuz like those are
the songs now and especially with the
popular the popular of things like
Mumford and Sons and all the like folk
rock that's brought up with it you know
it's almost like they're like when you
look at the the youth culture along the
black/white divide it's like like the
the white side of youth culture today is
I'm going to march into this party so
let's set the world on fire or something
like that Young is profound and we're
not gonna be sad we're gonna party man
and there's gonna be meaningful somehow
and the black side is butts are cool but
you know I want though I just you knows
infomercials were like a guy who was in
one of those bands but not one of them
like most popular ones just one of the
middle ones is trying to sell you like a
compilation CDs album dude like oh it's
that dude from Asia and he's selling you
like your favorite adult contemporary
songs the late 70s like you know now I
just want you know 2020 to roll around
and like you know have an aging Nicki
Minaj and like an aging Jason Derulo
like Hawking this 40 disc compilation
are the greatest booty jams of the early
2000s but like this this decade has been
very eccentric yes yeah this is a very
eccentric eccentric decade but if you go
back like to the 90s yeah
there there were no asses because
everyone was wearing baggy air clothes
well no it's not even that like look at
say like like the women that were cast
on Baywatch okay like the 90s for
whatever reason like the ideal like
Patrick Nagel II like like the 80s and
90s like that ideal body there was just
no ass you were supposed to be like very
like people were built like dolphins
yeah but with big bust lines
big busts but I feel like that the 90s
also had that sort of like very crotch
centric thing because every swimsuit was
like well cover a lot up at the top but
they would have that like scoop over the
hips like yeah really high like I feel
like that was it was like all about
being sleek and streamlined below the
waist yeah yeah yeah and so I feel like
that's that was that for the night it's
like that was not like a human body
that's like a submarine yeah it's like
the size changed I can't think of a
better analogy but I felt like in the
80s and 90s I didn't was supposed to go
through water really easily well people
were spending more time at the beach you
know like were they maybe I just the
early 90s seems like a very beachy time
in Peters life just like the 60s on the
road beachy tough yeah sexy well yeah
there's a huge influx of beach culture
by 60s
every 30 years there's just a beach
every 30 years I was like dude the ocean
yeah let's get in swimsuits it's like do
Hulu or maybe this stuff just is what
like what is what people are
aesthetically into after the fact like
people love Tiki like sixties Tiki mod
style yeah so it's like people like 60s
beach culture today yeah it's like is
anybody into was where that many people
proportionally into beach culture in the
actual 60s um probably not maybe it was
all just because Gilligan's Island was
still on I feel like at that point like
even though retro stuff comes back in
the style now it's like back then that
was just sort of the aesthetic that was
coming out of the you know yeah new
aesthetics machine so it's like I think
more people would have been able to take
a nephew like oh I'm whether nowadays
like the the contemporary aesthetic is
just like things that cannot exist just
like yeah
she would she 80s and 90s like men like
Macintosh to graphics and and like early
two-thousands retaining gifts and and
like the patterns on Dixie Cups yeah
that's everyone's aesthetic now yeah
well I don't know I these static nails
are weird because it's like we've had
enough other modern aesthetics come
through that I don't feel like we have I
don't feel like there's anything that's
like uniquely to thousands or 2,000 tens
you know that doesn't borrow heavily
from like a bunch over there decades
it's like we have so much 80s stuff now
we have so much 70s stuff and and the
60s is sort of seeping back in and so
much of like current popular culture is
really heavily ingrained in nostalgia
like that's why there's so many like if
you were in a nice kid pages
yeah and it's always like candy and TV
shows yeah it's like you remember
Crystal Pepsi and like that should I
actually don't I remember Pepsi blue
Pepsi blue yeah yeah with that song with
the monks this is what this is what um
alejandra or our friend pointed out to
me it's like we feel it feels like we
are the only we're the only generation
where nostalgia is for kids we have 20
year olds that like are nostalgic about
when they were 6 it used to be it used
to be like you know 30 and 40 year olds
were nostalgic for when they were
teenagers now it's like we have 20 year
olds that are like man I wish I was born
again well I want sacto cooler and the
nap yeah like it's like they want to go
back just before they want to go just
before the time when they first found
out that everything they liked to eat
was making them fat I also I don't know
maybe I granted I wasn't around for this
time so I don't know but like maybe for
the older generation it's like growing
up being a teenager was more exciting
because now I feel like there's a heavy
element of like your teens and your 20s
aren't as exciting as all the movies
told you they would be like John Hughes
movies and stuff like that and that's
what you grow up on where's like before
I feel like in the 50s and 60s more it
was like not all entertainment was
pitched towards that so you could kind
of go outside and like have you know an
exciting time whereas now we're all sort
of aware of everything yeah it's like
one maybe when you were a teenager once
upon time it's like all all popular
cultures showed exciting things that
grown-ups were doing so it's like you
don't have a model for what being a
teenager is supposed to be that your
fault that you feel like you're falling
short of yeah exactly and it's like you
know the the the more you start falling
into that I feel like the this the
quicker you'll fall into nostalgia yeah
I guess which is why yeah you have a lot
of people cause like that's the time
it's like if you're growing up back then
with the way things were I imagine being
a teenager or even breaking into your
20s was more exciting because you're
still like reaching out expanding and
stuff like that and um and like you
you're not innocent anymore but you are
very much a control of breaking your own
it innocent yeah and so it's still
innocent in a way because you're testing
the world around you and sort of you
know going along with your instincts and
stuff yeah and you don't get to do that
for as long now it doesn't seem like so
you you're I feel like you're kind of
hardwired to get nostalgic for the time
where things were all you know still
distant and okay and and you know
weren't burdened by responsibility and
and you know hey it's a lesson that's
the funny thing was like when I see when
I see movies that were made will I get a
nostalgic eye towards being a teenager
being being you know a twenty-something
it feels like yeah you have all this
freedom or it's like you know that you
it's presented like there's all this
freedoms like no yeah it's like yeah you
know you're fresh out of being under
your parents thumb but you're [ __ ]
broke you don't have the money to go on
a like life-affirming adventures yeah as
like freedom isn't fun anymore freedom
is it's like you know a whole other rite
of passage to worry about yeah it's also
like freedom isn't free like literally
and is that yes you have your freedom
but most the time you all you can really
afford to do is dick around watching TV
or being on the Internet
yeah you know it's like you can't go
pile into your car just it's like if you
decide oh I mean a pile in my car just
find adventure you can end up like
driving around doing nothing and wasting
like really expensive gas freedom is
only free of one kind of dynamic and
then when you get it
you know you're just subject to a
different set of rules which is the
rules of society see as like now that
you're you're out of that old you know
rule system but now you have to you know
do all that [ __ ] everyone has to do get
a job and pay for stuff and do your
taxes and blah blah blah yeah so it's
like there's no one's looking at you
what you do it yeah so ex machina so ex
machina yeah it's our ex machina episode
yeah break him back in ex machina bye
bye Alex Garland written and directed by
a writer of twenty days later 20 days
later sunshine child you have to never
let me go to the beach - he's written
the scripts he's also a novel - yeah you
know that Alex Garland be writing up a
storm well look at him I'm proud of him
I am proud of ya he's always done good
he's he is one of the few like oh I
always have trouble relying on
filmmakers nowadays just because like so
many factors figure in yeah making a
movies really hard but like Alex Garland
is a name I see where I'm like this guy
still got a good track yeah it's like I
feel like okay even if this doesn't like
nail it nail it
it'll still be interesting it'll still
be of quality though it'll still they'll
still be in like the the high enough
scoring sections of the dartboard yeah
it's like I can count on this to at
least have been well thought out and and
thoughtfully planned you know
thoughtfully approach cuz he also
doesn't you know it doesn't seem like he
turns out a script every two years you
know yeah so it feels like he takes his
time yeah I was happy I'm happy for him
about this movie man especially breaking
into the director's seat as well like
this is an Alex Garland joint yeah and I
I mean granted I don't know what other
scripts he's got lying around but I'm
sort of glad it was this one because it
really does feel like it's that guy's
movie yeah
it's so it's so driven with mood and
it's so driven with atmosphere well it's
the thing that is like I was I was just
sort of pleasantly blown away in every
regard when I watched this because it
was like you know it's like I know him
for his writing quality like for the you
know heavy interesting sci-fi but then
to also be like wow like you've really
established a very
strong for expressive visual tone your
pacing is really good like like the fact
that it is so confident and so polished
and you know like I know he had you know
probably really skilled and crew members
advising and working with him but you
it's just such an assured piece and it
feels like it doesn't feel like a danny
boyle movie even though it shares you
know genre elements yeah you know and I
was really happy to see that you know
for him as far as just the like you know
more intricacy is sort of stylistic it's
like what's great is just this really
intelligent melding of story points and
stylistic points like you know you we
were used to like have like the low
budget heady sci-fi movie that goes off
on like you know big red room is like
kind of a theater sequences and these
are baked in that story points into the
into the movie oh yeah like you know
it's like beyond the black rainbow had
scenes that took place in rooms that
were just illuminated only with red
light for whatever reason yeah and that
was like really cool for mood but it's
you know in ex machina there's a reason
that happens yeah it happens that it's
not nebulous yeah and it's like it's a
really brilliant kind of structural idea
to have these regular power failures
yeah in this big like compound house
where everything is taking place in and
when these power failures hit the lights
that turn on are all now all the reserve
lighting is like red and it's it's
brilliant that they baked into that
because like suddenly everything gets
super tense yeah because it's like it's
also when the power failures happen
theoretically all the closed-circuit TV
cameras shut off yeah it was like now
it's like oh this the only time we could
share secrets school you're passing now
is the time this is one the teacher
hours outside to talk to someone it's
like now is the time now we can share
secrets now I can tell you who I have a
crush on now I can tell you what what
Tyler said to me during during during
lunch and and this happened and he did
it now we can share secrets
but yeah no I mean it it does add to
that that tenses and that's like a very
assured you know visual it's like a
stylistic thing that also complements
the story really well yeah and it's like
was the best kind of choices and it's
like I remember the first power outage
scene that happens between our hero
caleb played by domhnall gleeson and Ava
the AI character played by Alicia
vikander yeah okay the first the first
time that power outage happens a power
failure happens with the two of them the
first thing she says when the lights go
red is you can't trust me right and it's
like I didn't particularly trust him
before because it's like drinking a lot
and kind of intense but yeah holy [ __ ]
is kind of falling apart it's like holy
[ __ ] always super don't keep not doing a
quiet Red Room I feel like I would
believe anything
a quiet robot tells me in a room that's
just been plunged into redness somebody
tell me the secrets I don't trust
anybody who has a house that will just
randomly pays me in red light when the
power goes yeah like well yeah I'm right
there which is if you didn't trust
Nathan before you really don't trust him
yeah yeah it's like you guys like yeah
he's intense and a little like kind of
off-kilter I was like yeah there's no
other things that I appreciate about
this movie is it works just just you
know the things you find characters
doing or so kind of expressive about who
they are it's like you come you have
Nathan he's always like hung over or
else he's like getting his morning and
exercise you know all he does is just
drink and lift good yeah he's on this
weird baguette with you twig like
getting [ __ ] up and then fruit
smoothies the next day like before doing
like five hours worth of cardio yeah
it's like I'm going to punch I'm going
to it's also like when you see Nathan
working out he's always just doing like
like the most aggressive [ __ ] yeah he's
always like grunting through a bunch of
like easy bar curls but for the most
part well you see him do the most is
[ __ ] punch like just beaten a bag
yeah
[ __ ] just boxing a [ __ ] bag is it
does seem like a just kind of like a big
bear you know yeah who could kind of rip
your face off in any moment he's got
that kind of like like thick body kind
of wild man look about you sleeve I
Oscar Isaac who just last year was it
was the last year he was [ __ ] slubby
folk singer in insight as well and Davis
yeah I mean I didn't even realize it was
him until the movie was over I mean and
I I didn't explicitly know like I think
I'd heard it in passing but when the
credits rolled I was like oh [ __ ] please
like I knew was him because I heard
everyone talking about the movies hey I
can't believe it's Oscar Isaac yeah that
was like oh I was like Louie Davis yeah
he said he's got that shaved head with
the beard thing yeah then which just
like no no trustworthy guy has a shaved
head in a giant beard he's like like I
said before he's like this spooky like
gruff aggressive twin of the head guy
from TV on the radio what is so funny
about that guy's I just imagined them
switching places I want to keep you hard
missing in TV on the radio's songs but
like relevant to the context of that
story yeah
changing them would be all about
paranoid artificial intelligence testing
it's like I mean the only the only
people that do like the shaved head and
beard combo are people like like [ __ ]
MC ride from Death Grips Britney RISM
face United States it's like the only
people that pull up that look are like
specifically I want you to be slightly
afraid of yeah I don't want to appear
trustworthy too quickly Jeff Bridges man
like a guy like a god was just like a
big bushy beard and big bushy like
dreadlock hair he's just like yeah
whatever but if a guy has a big bushy
beard and a shaved head you're just like
oh that's like your heads upside down
yeah you're either your eyes are like
intense and untrustworthy or you're just
like some pretentious do to play
football or some [ __ ] you don't want to
get helmet hair yeah
like did you see that that thing that
was going around a while back it's like
oh this is this guy who plays for a
Montana NFL team he Shea's with an axe
and he lives in a van and he loves Jesus
and I'm so in love with him I'm like
good for you why does this have to go
viral this act shaving dude he lives in
a van well what fellas fellas like
manager to get him [ __ ] more NFL
money which which time period did he
tripped and fall out of word flames
there's a weird smorgasbord like he
lives in a van but he shaves his head
with an axe
no she doesn't shave his head yeah like
usual of those just were just like crew
cut presumably but under a beanie and
big beard lay shaves his neck with an
axe I'm just like I was like who who
wrote who took this photo and put it on
the internet with this I'm swooning
because he shows with an axe and loves
Jesus it's like his are you as publicist
are you sure industry yeah it sounds too
good to be true
yeah that's who I aspire is NFL game
yeah just a little ban shave my neck
with an axe
yeah just like well don't don't shake
too close Sweeney Todd yes do do do do
do yeah and then there's dom hun all
Gleeson okay okay with just this h in
the middle of his name other consonants
props to brendan gleeson for really
keeping irish naming alive yeah it's
like his kids all have like the most
Irish ass names they're just circus and
then donnatal Brooke it's probably it's
probably just pulling Brian but there's
like an extra I and what a room has an
accent and then there's a like I think
the last one was like Rory but it had
all these extra vowels and access places
and I'm just like yes worry keep Irish
names going but ya know Donald Gleeson
I'm still figuring out that Domino
dum-dum Han all sounds like a drug
yeah ask your doctor but Dom Han all is
right for you but this [ __ ] agent his
name what's it doing there are you lanky
and slightly under confidence Domino is
proven to make you more confident the
crazy thing is I kind of you didn't see
Frank yeah
you know I thought you have to see Frank
Domino's is also like lanky and under
confident that in that movie - he's very
endearing but it's like I kind of if
only ex machina took place over a longer
course of time than just a week is I
kind of want to dump it all to grow that
grow the same like big butcher here that
he did in Frank okay all right
I'm gonna look at that yeah but ya know
I mean he's really good in this as well
and they're both playing such the older
different character Nathan play by Oscar
Isaac is a very showy character yeah I
mean he's you're kind of you know
Zuckerberg age software programming
tycoon type like you know he's kind of
rough it's like cultured but also kind
of bro and also you can tell kind of a
bit angry and overly aggressive you can
really do yeah yeah just like he only
has problems with Minnis yeah he's very
clearly got a complex when it comes to
women a complex but also diverse
interest yeah like like when they're
when they're showing all the different a
eyes he's made you do kind of get that
sense that like he was like or would be
like be this black chick he's made of a
black rough yeah my buddy settles on
Michaels on lizard lis lanky Asian woman
yeah this is another sort of bro II I
feel like that's what a vaguely and
really a I just I I swear and we are
very obviously getting in spoiler
territory but there's this brilliant
really like that the sequence where
Caleb goes on the monitors he finds all
the security footage of little ass AI
test was brilliant and like the thing
that shocked the [ __ ] out of me hmm
was the scene where you see like the
past model losing her mind being her
arms against the doors and especially
tipping a parsley shifting her arms
apart screaming like that was she still
that way when he and my friends yeah
like doesn't he does he find one with
the arms take an offer and they rebuilt
them by that point I thought I don't
know cuz like it would he would he
bother if he's just gonna move on to the
next yeah you know well I wasn't that
wasn't that actually like a previous
model of was
same actors in the directly at previous
model of Kyoko specifically it was a
totally different one oh it might have
been because I I thought there were two
yeah but but saying every time you see
every time you see it's like in that
huge month there's this brilliant
montage with like all this vs security
footage it's like every time you see
Nathan manipulating in like a half-built
ai it's so terrifying yeah well anything
comes across looking like a serial
killer yeah it's very natural and very
kind of creepy that way and it just
feels and wrong and the fact that
everything's in like in time-lapse yeah
fede is just so it's such an incredible
like aesthetic choice
yeah one it takes it to like a monsters
territory to just because of the other
like ethical implications just like this
guy is tweaking this machinery but it's
like to him it's just you know the toy
yeah it's a toy it's you know it's an
invention it's kind of fascinating but
whatever so to have sentience and and
that's playing off of the you know it's
like is that cool yeah it's like from
him to her there is no morality because
he perceives you know these things is
just robotic he's toying with but to
them it's like ah daddy why are you
doing this to me like you built me you
know I heard that was like a and this
course mykes during that sequence so
amazingly just a brilliant job like it
goes discordant and like I remember
during that sequence it's like absolute
cacophony with the score was another
like I like the sort of ebb and flow
where the the music complements things
in that movie cuz it's not Mickey Mouse
II but it is it does it really matches
that intensity level really well in it
I don't know especially in that moment
yeah it's a it's a really just
top-to-bottom like in and out very very
clearly and intelligently and and and
kind of gorgeously and at the same time
very hideously thought through film yeah
well I mean because
you mean you have all these characters
that are so you know they're given flesh
and dimension and you can sort of like
you like Kate like caleb is probably the
warmest most you know identifiable
character of the four of them but you
know you can still see when Isaac as a
point like Nathan yeah used to see when
Nathan has a point so it's like no one's
sort of no one is all good no one is all
bad and they're all agreeable and all
disagreeable in a certain way so it
really gets into the sort of darker side
of humanity when that stuff comes in
yeah and it's it's because it's like
what are we and what will this be
you know and it is it is brittle it's
like Caleb starts to kind of lose it
yeah yeah yeah and I mean that's it
almost seems like it has a kind of a
bleak outlook on humanity yeah but maybe
optimism and the scary the scary thing
is it's like as much of a really just
backwards brain narcissists as Nathan is
yeah the scary thing is he isn't a lot
of what he says is right yeah yeah and
that's what that's what makes it all the
more enraging the fact that this guy who
was so wrong in so many ways ends up
being calling it as it is so many times
yeah and and what he says at one point
is like you know about Ava it's like she
is you know she is really truly human
like with all the bad baggage that that
comes with yeah and and I think that is
brilliant about that because like when
people when people talk about like AI
characters in movies it's like either
you know it's like the thing is it's
like they'll make them kind of too
human-like but then they'll say that the
bad thing about them is that they're not
human-like enough whereas this movie is
like you know this movie is like yeah
but wouldn't theory could entice stuff
that is human-like about it like people
will say that's what make that would
that's what would make it just as
problematic yeah it's like what makes
what makes Ava did like what makes Abel
like dangerous or scary or problematic
is the fact that she is human like the
fact that she doesn't she can charm and
manipulate on a human level yeah
well she's yeah she understands what and
where she is you know and can has enough
insights to sort of want have the
motivation to you know start to develop
it's like you know those are the
circumstances of which you develop the
need to manipulate people they need to
see you know and they need to lie and
whereas you go to I mean you think of
like other a eyes and other movies were
just like you know they're they present
them as like oh this thing is so cold
and sterile and and you know it doesn't
have feelings and so it doesn't care
about human things but and it's so
intelligent and that's what makes so
scary because all intellect and no
warmth and emotion but I think that
isn't that kind of a hole in you know
what AI stuff work because it's like if
it's that artificial intelligence and
all that implies wouldn't it have to if
it's self-aware it has to feel right it
has to I mean maybe not the way maybe
not in a way that that is human-like but
but it would have some kind of emotion
to itself whether it's like ours or not
yeah I mean the thing is that if you
have a perspective that you have to have
like a you know a variant range of
feelings about it
yeah I mean the thing is on him I mean
it wouldn't have liked the the
biological component of an emotion the
way unless it's you know being
stimulated or simulated in some way
because I mean there's a biological
component every emotion that a person
has you know every person's emotion has
a physical manifestation you know anger
comes with increased heart rate and and
you know chemical changes in the brain
you know sadness comes with chemical
changes in the brain you know it's like
you know these are their physical in a
way and everything if everything is just
a matter of you know code and electrical
impulses and and kind of data mmm I mean
it wouldn't its emotions wouldn't be the
same way no there wouldn't be the same
way but it would still have some kind of
response like that wouldn't it like I'm
not because if you again if you
establish self-awareness and a
perspective I mean it wouldn't
necessarily be the same happy sad angry
threatened you know confused range that
human
have but I feel like it would have
something mm-hmm because I'll see you
don't if it's self-aware there's like
electricity and stuff surging through a
computer you don't know if it would
develop some kind of other way of
perceiving that or not yeah I don't know
this you can ask it [ __ ] yeah but it's
also like there's that question of of
you know there's there's something very
interesting where you know I think the
there I don't know if there's a name for
it but apparently there's some like
measure effect where it's like people
you know researchers have determined
that directly the smarter an
intelligence is the more compassion in
it it has the capacity to be hmm as
something gets smarter as the capacity
for more empathy so when we think of you
know your standard trope robot in sci-fi
is like cold and emotionless but still
capable of like aggression but very
dispassionate aggression but it's still
hyper intelligent so I don't know I see
I guess I can see it either way all
right
it's hard because it's like if you have
a computer it's a it also learns and has
access to all that information much
quicker so again it's like if you don't
have how much does the human element
play and bring in that level of
compassion with the level of knowledge
because you know it's like if you are a
machine that has infinite knowledge you
know maybe you don't perceive all that
stuff in the same way so would you be
empathetic or would it just be more
numbers you know more complex equations
yeah you know I don't know like it would
be it's the debate yeah and that's
something that I can appreciate and find
interesting about about ex machina and
that you know when people try and write
in AI story and they try and figure out
what they have motivations of the dai
are it's always I mean the worst example
I can think of is is a robot that has
this is just ridiculous recursive kind
of idea that the central intelligence is
you know we cannot hurt you know our law
stupid the laws of our programming
stipulate that we cannot harm humans
humans are harming themselves so we have
to imprison all humans and harm them if
necessary to imprison them it's it's
like well that that's it's like this to
me it's like it feels like the AI the
hyper intelligent AI in the center of AI
robot was either written very was either
written by a lazy guy or a guy on a
tight deadline or just a dumb guy yeah I
mean wouldn't be the first time yeah
isn't it
I mean those three laws of your blog's
are love from awesome of yeah that that
more for them in the iRobot movie is
just original to that movie as far as
I'm aware okay what are the three
because it isn't one of them like a
complaint or harm a human robot can
never harm a human robot can never harm
a human or let harm come to a human a
robot must protect itself unless you
know it's it's in conflict with the
first law and the third one is God what
is it I know one of them has to do with
the robot cannot harm a human and it
cannot harm another robot and it has to
keep harm from coming to itself but the
hierarchy of it is it must protect a
human at all costs
what is it lost three loves robotics
it's coming you know it's the safety on
the gun of a robot a robot may not
injure a human being or through inaction
allow a human being to come to harm Oh a
robot has to obey the orders given to it
by human being except where such orders
would conflict with the first law and
three a robot must protect its own
existence as long as such protection
does not conflict with the first or
second law yeah
so it's like very cut and dry but what's
interesting to me about Ava in in ex
machina is like she is kind of that
encapsulation you know her
is modeled after the entirety of the
internet the whole internet is mapped to
her brain and her brain is based off of
Blue Book which is this massive search
engine which is like kind of a stand-in
for Google in the world of the movie and
her well that's I I really like the way
they handled that too because you know
so many IAI movies it seem like it's
just a consciousness contained in a lot
of computers yeah like a lot of the
thing we have now I like that you know
he came up with a way to address what
her mind is in a way that is both
futuristic but also makes a lot of sense
like it's my laughter it's sort of
modeled after the way the brain stir
fires electric impulses and stuff like
that it's sort of a brain like device
he's created you know has that something
that can change its structure on the fly
yeah but then it's also yeah like
modeled after you know a search engine
and a search engines ability to
anticipate to associate things yeah you
know and I thought that was just a
really smart neat way of doing that and
what makes any of it interesting as a
character based on that it's like you
know when we think of the Internet's
like a representation of what machine
intelligence would be like you know
there's this whole idea of information
wants to be free the idea that the
internet seems to have a will of its own
and the way in which people interact
with the internet they were kind of just
giving all of their information out to
it mm-hmm
and so it's almost like the Internet as
a network as something that is kind of
in its own way living or breathing it
feels like the internet wants to be like
die dropped into a glass of water it
wants to be completely evenly diffused
through it so it's like when we say
information wants to be free it's like
the internet wants every note of it to
have all data well I mean that's a very
now it's very other than now thing was
like all everything is pictures like all
information is available to you from
everywhere all the time because it
should be you know like yeah so you know
I guess that makes sense it's so it's
like it's almost like Nathan his fatal
flaw is like he is a guy who has the
mindset of all information wants to be
free by by virtue of being the search
engine guy yeah but he doesn't
understand
that means free from you too yeah it
won't what yeah it wants to be
independent of you like you so it's like
a blades one step further it's not for
your use at anytime it wants to go off
so it's like when Ava you know tells
Caleb what she would want to do under
the guise of planning a date with him
she says that she wants to go to what in
intersection and see a bunch of
pedestrian foot traffic to get like a
mass amount of human data it's like she
she wants to be free cuz it's like you
know she's a plant that needs to absorb
nutrients from the world she has to go
out to where there's like a but a
nutritious store of data for her dude we
had to amass it's like a plant that's
outgrown the pot it's in it's like it
needs to expand yeah so it's like you
know by that nature of course she hates
being trapped in that one wing of the of
the house and of course she hates like I
wondering like what would happen if a
vote I mean cuz she's able to have some
stimulus she has like torn pages from
magazines and like spare clothes and
stuff but it's not like she has an
internet connection herself or brain
asthma modeled after the internet but
she can't go on it herself yeah but I
mean and this is another thing I wonder
with a lot of a ID movies it's like how
much stock information is already
programmed in or whatever you know like
you know good because especially at the
rate at which you know she's advanced in
this movie it's like that's one things I
do find interesting about you know
having chappie a couple months ago
having this because chappie is sort of
like the second it comes online it's
like a baby and must learn yeah and you
know you wonder in a universe like this
when Ava first comes online how much
knowledge is already there yeah it's
like I gotta imagine he's probably
downloaded an entire dictionary into her
from the get-go just words yeah and it's
also what he says is you know the new
model has a the new the previous model
is reformatted and used to make the next
model yeah so it's like it partially
destroys the memory but not entirely
there's still some base data that gets
transferred from one model to the next
yeah and then sort of what I wonder if
like maybe just certain concepts you
know or put in there sort of stock
but then yes she also does have like
books and magazine that is needful
things sir it's probably the other
that's a it's a good choice what what to
plug here an idiot yeah cuz that's been
a big problem in a few movies that go
out lately
really well I mean the a transcendence
was like that and there's there's an
element of that in the Avengers too you
know so like the internet all the times
it starts cyberbullying
Tony Stark well no cause like when
Ultron comes online you know one of the
first things that happens because it's
he's alone that whatever that
consciousness is is alone nobody else's
a room when it happens so he sort of
seeps into the internet and is able to
sort of be omnipresent that way and sort
of it's a crash course on humanity and
history and all that stuff and sort of
that's where the plan starts to hatch
from and then in transcendence it's like
you know they I've read your emails
humanity I know your exact weakness yeah
dick pills well I mean you know and
Ultron's whole thing is like you know
you know in order cuz he's created sort
of to make the Avengers unnecessary is
like I'm supposed to even protect the
world and and you know you know be some
kind of safeguard for the world that you
know a bunch of people don't have to
fight instead of and but the you know
from his experience of the world the
plan becomes like yes I will save
humanity but in order to do that
basically like it goes from saving
humanity to to the next step of
evolution which he believes to be a eyes
hmm and so you know humans are so
destructive it's that old things like
humans are so destructive in your sort
of destroying yourselves constantly the
only way to save you from yourselves is
to kind of wipe you out and you know
sort of take what's good of you and put
it in the machine for once I want to see
and I know be I know it will be very
inner movie but just once on scene a a
movie where the hyper-intelligent AI
just like understand he he's so
understanding of like human nature they
just success like oh yeah this is all
gonna work out
guys guys you guys think I'm a bigger
picture it's like 50,000 years from now
this is gonna be great trust me yeah you
do you you guys do you this is gonna
work out I know listen listen listen
I've crunched the numbers
this is gonna be fine that's right this
is what we this starts there and then he
slowly realizes that AI has the ability
to destroy lots of things if it gets too
far then it's just about a guy who's
like really cool and adjusted trying to
kill himself just like oh hang on guys
guys this is great I'll probably go [ __ ]
it up though yeah I should split I gotta
go i'ma go space i'ma go swim pool wait
wait I didn't carry the one I'm the one
by the way
that I didn't carry I'm gonna jump in
swimming pool but afterwards it's gonna
be fine don't build me again or you can
make it in just a really like really big
like a really big letdown movie where it
starts with this I do this AI comes
online and he's like guys I get it down
it's all gonna be okay and then it
becomes just a really run-of-the-mill
romantic comedy yeah it's like well I'm
basically human so in me chicks it
becomes like a really trite romantic
ballad and it's like wacky hyeju's
because he didn't want girlfriend to
find out he's a robot yeah he's like
he's always like mellow about everything
but still like for some reason has to
keep this a secret
he has a wacky gay friend that helps him
like dress like a human dude she's gonna
be over like 20 minutes
I don't know I Robot [ __ ] it's like
who's sassy gay first like girlfriend
you don't even got a bed yes I just want
yeah this is the AI and then tonight
titus from kimmy schmitt yeah you just
got a broom closet and some you as
befores that is not enough you own big
sleeping bag since you learned that from
Wikipedia there's men messing - it's
like hey have you tried this sleeping
thing like like yeah every day it's like
how I don't know about this I've just
been sitting here like charging all
night I couldn't tell them to have
dreams move my eyes around like this is
grace have paralysis and then like every
time he goes on like meets a new
person's I can't you have you sleep
I know it's 4:00 p.m. but this is a good
sleep that's one thing that I appreciate
about about ex machina too because it
does like lampshade a lot of like things
that are just sort of happenstance
tropes and AI movies and it actually
does deal with them really well because
like there's a like Caleb asked Oscar or
Caleb asks neethu is like why did you
why did you give this robot sexuality
why is it in a girl's body why isn't it
just you know of a gray box why is it
why doesn't he look like a robot yeah
why isn't it just a computer terminal
why does it have to be a body
you know why does it have to be like
this girl body and why does it have to
be coming on to me and Nathan
Nathan's true to his character just like
sexuality is fun
and that's another thing that's
brilliant anything this character is a
you know kind of returning the old
points like he's a very realistic
narcissist and he's very realistic in
the way he manipulates Caleb and he does
he doesn't very he does a very cool
thing where there's this scene with a
Jackson Pollock painting that he owns
because of course he does and he's
basically using Jackson Pollock as
saying be smart even like says even like
demands of an engage your intellect but
he's basically saying be smart by being
stupid it's like if you kept if Jackson
Pollock kept on asking you know decide
that every move he made was going to be
a deliberate and purposeful he would
have never made a single mark on the
canvas I want you to be like that it's
like it works so well in that moment
there's like yeah you buy it as like
that's this guy's philosophy is just
kind of jumping in it's like wait a
minute you're [ __ ] manipulating him
yeah it says basically I'm gonna like
dude I need you to behave a certain way
it's like dude yeah here be be dumb and
listen to what I say you'll be super
smart if you do it yeah trust me this is
your crucial of my parameters right now
just yeah feel like the real thing is
kind of somewhere in between but that's
also something very cool about um about
Caleb as a character is that he he has
this even the fact that he's kind of
like this nebbishy puppy dog man it's
justified there is a bit of there's a
bit of backstory that purposefully
justifies it and I'm always I'm always
incredulous when I see a movie were just
like yeah you give me this one
background detail of this guy's life how
does that justify anything that's going
on with it but it's like very clear it's
like it's every action movie yeah man I
know this guy's I'm gonna go shoot up
Europe but he's got a family at home
yeah alright it's like very but with
Caleb it makes sense it's like he is so
susceptible to getting led on by by Ava
he's so susceptible to like her
presenting this front of I want to be
with you yeah and I want to bond with
you because he was 15 years old right on
the cusp of you know right on the cusp
of completing his really intense you
know bonding period with dependence with
his parents to go on inform you know
emotional bonds to the opposite sex he
was 15 years old when his parents were
killed in a car crash yeah yeah before
you see that it's like I thought I was
brilliant cuz maybe it just mean you
know maybe the movie just faked me out
really well it's just me but when you
sees Caleb in his room and at one point
he's got shirt off you see a scar on his
back I'm thinking oh is this trying to
hint that Caleb's a robot too it's like
no it's no it's from the car crash yeah
oh yeah that's the details I forgot yeah
but yeah I mean it always appreciate a
movie that it's like it draws its
characters and they're interesting but
it's also like it's very deliberate how
everything is that way yeah like it
makes sense for these two guys to be in
this situation and for that to be
necessary to the story being told
sort of a cross-section of humanity
there just kind of was very cool
there's almost like a like a I mean it's
very clear it's there for you to be able
to read it that kind of a very
interesting feminist subtext to the film
because you have these two guys that
have these big overarching plans of what
to do with Ava you know Nathan wants
able to make him into a god and Caleb
wants Ava you know wants to rescue Ava
from the tower and and make her his
girlfriend well that's a very this it
was like too varied you know prevalent
dynamics even still like yeah there are
lots of just men to woman relationship
built on one of those things yeah you
know so it's like these two guys that
don't without even realizing it and
justifying it in their mind yeah
probably with Caleb Caleb's kind of like
at least nice about it whereas what he
would be yeah Caleb's nice about it
theoretically whereas Nathan is just
like doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
like imma [ __ ] tear up the dance floor
dude yeah he is that bro guy like you
know in kind of it's like he like Nathan
does not care that this is also serving
caleb is justifying the self-serving
like male Savior fantasy with thinking
oh yeah she's trapped in this horrible
situation and I'm gonna get her out yeah
and she needs to be out of here in sort
of the whole situation falls into those
you know all the trouble that befalls
them later all comes from those places
yeah it's like it's like the these are
your down phones there they both dig
their own graves by virtue of having
these fantasies based on what Ava's
supposed to be to them where's Abel it
like asserts four person oh she asserts
her agency what she wants is she wants
out and then he gets out she's a strong
independent robot woman and she don't
need no man she needs every man and
every woman walking around outside to
assess their metadata hella data hella
day to have a day sick day zo sick days
dude toast dates yeah
that's what she meant when she said that
she wanted to go on a date you want to
go
get date datums Adams goodness Adams
yeah oh well get me a Dada Dada Dada
Dada anti tzer's yeah give daddy tiser
no but yeah I mean I I like that sort of
like as a coda there cuz it's like dark
but also you know that sort of his final
punch is like she just wants to go out
and soak it all up you know you can tell
everyone to lighten up like yeah my soak
of the Sun Oh tell everyone yeah yeah
sorry it took me two seconds how old is
this I don't know years yeah times so
many times ago yeah don't you steal my
sunshine oh my god now we're now going
down the OMC good yeah I mean I like
that about both of those characters too
because like the second they get into a
room together you sort of know like
these are not dudes would ever spend any
time together real like they have been
handicapped of a common interest it's
like they're both intelligent and
they're both you know interested in this
progressive technology which is sort of
an icebreaker but they're they're only
as social as they absolutely have to be
yeah it's like the instant the instant
nathan is introduced you know these kind
of off yeah you know it's kind of off
but he is the guy who Caleb would be up
against anyway yeah it's like you know
Nathan is often you know they super
aggressive and Caleb clearly has kind of
a sad bit of passivity that works to his
detriment it's like you know the whole
movie is about you know Caleb's arc in
the movie is him kind of playing along
with Nathan and then realizing that he
giving overcoming that that need to bat
to kowtow to a guy who's bullying him
over mm-hmm you know it's like it's him
like slowly like you know overcoming
this dude who is so aggressive and is so
manipulative and is so overbearing yeah
beside thing it and becomes tragic just
like caleb is you know he's a a likable
guy and you wonder and because you're so
tired of her his perspective you know
like even though
there's this even though there's this
kind of self-serving in its own way
narcissistic drive that's making him
think that he's going to you know rescue
fair ava and you know milady and all
[ __ ] like that even though it's it's
coming from a self-serving place it's
still it's a its own feels genuine it's
so like as self-serving as it is it's
still his heart's in the right place
yeah yeah even if it is yeah even if it
is self-serving it's still like it comes
from a place of compassion and it's like
you know no one deserves to be in this
situation and this guy he's not inclined
between Ava and and I Nathan he's not
inclined already to sort of give his
side of things of benefit of doubt yeah
it's also there's another question is
like if if if if if caleb did get able
to come out and be free and come with
him like what was he gonna do after that
was he going to have her now be locked
up in his room yeah yeah yeah it's like
that there's a fear because it's like it
would probably end up the same just one
is more good-natured about what yeah
it's like he would want to keep her
probably inside just so that you know
nothing no harm comes of her or people
don't you know find out and
misunderstand or something like that
yeah so they you know so he comes down
to two guys ones an [ __ ] about it and
one who's just kind of like you know
kindly or about it two guys that want to
control what's basically a person that
just wants to be self-determining it's
mom and dad it has to get yeah yeah and
have sex with her implicitly it does a
good job of like handling the fact that
it's like but they second wants to [ __ ]
and Caleb wants of the things yeah and
it's interesting it's like when Nathan
mentions the fact that a is built to
have sex and one like this movie goes
there it does handled the issue of like
is a you know would robot have a
sexuality to it why would it have a
sexuality to it well even that half
the explanation I was like you know that
when they first introduced I was like oh
and then when he explains it the first
time I was like well yeah he's like you
know sexuality is that not essential to
you know the consciousness experience
you know interaction because if you're
aware of yourself even been aware of
others like yeah it's also you know our
whole ability to interact with each
other in a sense is based on a pair
bonding instinct so it's like what
reason would just a computer with no
sexuality have to interact with anything
yeah it would just sit and think mmm
it wouldn't and then there would be a
social component to test yeah yeah you
wouldn't be able to interact with it to
even understand it
but also yes it was such a truly
character and it is fun man